partons pour une visite de la
commanderie d'elancourt un peu
différente
vous jouez le rôle de jean pierre bacri
qui s'appelle nicolas dans le film
muni d'un casque audio les visiteurs
doivent suivre la bande sonore pour
devenir les héros de scènes de cinéma
une déambulation chorégraphique inédite
appelée api manif un demi tour dans ces
raconté me mets dans la commanderie qui
parle de l'histoire de la commanderie
mais qui fait le lien aussi aux projets
culturels de la commanderie api manif
mission fantaisie est une création de
david rolland un chorégraphe basé à
nantes
une commande qui l'a créée spécialement
pour la commanderie
si vous n'avez pas traîner en chemin
nous semble maintenant sur la pelouse
le pan le restaurant au mime danse chant
une déambulation ludique et très joyeuse
à l'aller
courtois
apa
hahaha
les participants ont tout donné pendant
une heure lors de cette api manif oui
j'adore me déplacer comme ça en dansant
le rythme me convient c'est original
on va dire après par rapport à ma
personnalité je sais pas si ça
correspond exactement mais il y avait de
l'énergie dans le groupe donc on se
prend quand même au jeu j'ai proposé que
ce soit faux boulot tous les matins
pendant 10 minutes
tout simplement cette api manif
organisée samedi à 15h à la commanderie
d'elancourt a rassemblé une vingtaine de
personnes